beginner social robots
have you heard about Tesla Tesla bot the
humanoid robot yes I have yes yes but I
don't exactly know what it's designed to
do to you you probably do uh no I know
it's designed to do but I I have a
different perspective on it but it's
designed to it's a humanoid form and
it's designed to for automation tasks in
the same way that industrial robot arms
automated task in the factory so it's
designed to automate task in the factory
but I think the humanoid form is what
we're talking about before
is um
is one that we connect with us human
beings anything anything legged honestly
but the humanoid form especially we
anthropomorphizes it most intensely and
so the possibility to me it's exciting
to see
both Atlas developed by Boston's
Dynamics and anyone including Tesla
trying to make humanoid robots cheaper
and more effective
this is the obvious way transforms the
world is social robotics to me versus
um
versus automation of tasks in the
factory so yeah I just wanted to in case
that was something you're interested in
because I I find it I find its
application social robotics super
interesting we did a lot of work with uh
pepper
um pepper the robot a while back we were
like the emotion engine for pepper uh
which is softbanks humanoid robot and
how tall is pepper it's like yeah like
um I don't know like
five foot maybe right yeah yeah pretty
pretty big pretty big
um and it was designed to be at like
airport lounges and you know retail
stores mostly customer service right
hotel lobbies
um
and I mean I don't know where the state
of the robot is but I think it's very
promising I think there are a lot of
applications where this can be helpful
I'm also really interested in
um yeah social robotics for the home
right like that can help elderly people
for example transport things from one
location of the home to the other or
even like just have your back in case
something happens
um yeah I don't know I I do think it's a
very interesting space it seems early
though do you feel like the timing is
now
I yes 100
uh so it always seems early until it's
not right right right I think the time
I definitely think
that the time is now like this decade
for social robots whether the humanoid
form is right I don't think so
I know I think uh the uh like if we just
look Jibo at Jibo as an example
I feel like most of the problem
the challenge the opportunity of social
connection between an AI system and a
human being does not require you to also
solve the problem of robot manipulation
and Mobility bipedal Mobility so I think
you could do that with just a screen
honestly but there's something about the
interface of Jibo we can rotate and so
on that's also compelling but you get to
see all these robot companies that are
fail that fail incredible companies like
Jibo and
um
even uh I mean the iRobot in some sense
is a big success story that it was able
to find right and a niche a niche thing
and focus on it but in some sense it's
not a success story because they didn't
build any other robot like any other it
didn't expand into all kinds of Robotics
like once you're in the home maybe
that's what happens with Amazon is
they'll flourish into all kinds of other
robots